[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
السلام عليكم مساكم الله بالخير جميعا
وشكرا على حضوركم
في عام 2017 حوالي قبل سته سنوات من الان
كنت في رحله طويله جدا ما بين روسيا
ومنغوليا
وكوريا الجنوبيه وتايوان
او بعدهم مختلفه اربعه لغات مختلفه ثلاثه
ابيان مختلفه والعديد من الثقافات
المتناقضه تعبت فيها كثير
ويوم بعرض ويوم حار ويوم في الصحراء
واسبوع في قطار
وانتهيت اخر شيء في طيران بعدها رجعت
السعوديه
يوم رجعت السعوديه في ثاني يوم لي كنت
اتصفح الانترنت ووقعت عيني على مقوله
لرحاله
امريكي اسمه
الشخص هذا سافر الف يوم حول العالم بعد ما
رجع كتب جمله بسيطه جدا وان توني راجع
تعبان
كان يقول باللغه الانجليزيه طبعا مترجمه
يقول انه لا يتطلب ان تكون غنيا لتسافر
ولا يتطلب
ان تكون
شجاعا لتسافر
هنا بديت اسال نفسي السؤال
هل انا فعلا شجاع
وهل انا فعلا غني
هل السفر يحتاج الى الشجاعه
مع المتعب
دائما ارجع السعوديه ناقص وزن واجهه
السعوديه مسمى وارجع سعوديه تعبان وابحث
عن الاجازه من الاجازه فهل فعلا السفر
يحتاج الى شجاعه والسفر يحتاج الى غنى
هذا الكلام كان قبل خمس سنين او قبل ست
سنوات عام 2017
في ذلك الوقت ما كنت مامن بالفقره كنت
اقول انه بدون فلوس ما تسافر وبدون شجاعه
ما تطلع من بيتكم لكن الان ما اشوف
الموضوع هذا صحيح واشوف المقوله هذه مئه
بالمئه صحيحه خلوني ارجع فيكم 16 سنه
وتحديدا في شهر اغسطس من العام 2006 توني
متخرج من الثانويه
شعب كل حياته متمحوظه ما بين البيت
والمدرسه والتحفيظ
توتي الى اللقاء ما يعرف شو يعني العالم
الخارجي فجاه جت اطول اجازه في حياه
الانسان الاجازه اللي بعد الثانويه امام
مستقبل مجهول جامعه كليه تخصص
اجبرت من الوالد قال لي اطلع شوف العالم
انت عايش ما بين البلاي ستيشن وما بين
الانترنت وما بين الكمبيوتر
في عام 2006 ما كانت فكره عمل الشباب في
المطاعم المقاهي زي الان وجدت نفسي شاب
عربي وحيد اعمل في سلسله مقاهي تكتب كيف
السعوديه
انتظر يمينه ويساوي امام الشعب من الفلبين
اندونيسيا الهند النيبال بنغلاديش هذول هم
اصحابك الان اصدقائي كل واحد في سبيله
وظيفه صيفيه مؤقته كما كان الاتفاق لمده
اربعه اشهر امتدت الى اربعه سنوات حبيت
الوضع تاقلمت عليه وصرت ادرس واشتغل
في الفتوى المسائيه اعمل دوام كامل بصفته
الصباحيه ادرس في تخصص التقنيه
هذه الاشهر خلتني
اندمج مع هذه الثقافات الاسيويه
شفتوا ناس من عالم اخر راتبهم قليل جدا
نصفه يوصل الى اهاليهم هنا بدات اتفائل
كيف يعيش الانسان في زمان ومكان اخر كيف
يعيش الانسان بالفلبين باندونيسيا وبالهند
وكيف حنا عايشين في منطقه الراحه واحد
عايش في بلده امن مطمئن
البديهيات عنده في مشقه بالنسبه لغيرها ما
نحس بقيمتها
بدات افكر
واستنتج انه انت قاعد هنا في الرياض في
شيء قاعد يصير في العالم
اطلع اشوف الدنيا كيف صايره وين تطلع وانت
يا دوبك كنت انسان بيتوته ما تعرف حتى
تتكلم اللغه الانجليزيه في ذاك الوقت ما
كنت تحل في اللغه الانجليزيه
رؤيه العالم
ليس كسياحه بحته هو رؤيه الانسان ابي افهم
الانسان كيف يفكر الانسان كيف يعيش
الانسان كيف يتاقلم مع الانسان الاخر كان
هذا الهدف وجدت الالهام من هؤلاء الشباب
وجدت الالهام والدافع للسفر من هذه
الوظيفه البسيطه اللي تعلمت منها شيء الى
يومك هذا ما تعلمته ما شفته في اي مجال
اخر هل السفر يحتاج الى شجاعه
في عام 2010 داخل دوله الخليج 2011 العالم
العربي
اجهل كيف اسافر ما اعرف كيف اسافر
حقائب
حقيبتين
مليئه بالملابس نصف الخزانه معي والعديد
من الاحذيه وكان معي توصيله ليش ما توصيله
ما اعرف كان معي مكواه ليش ماخذها ما ادري
كنت ماخذ اربع جاكيتات وشان واكشخ اوروبا
ايطاليا المانيا اسبانيا
البرتغال فرنسا قطاعات سيارات
الين ما وصلت
في احد المدن الالمانيه اتنقل بالقطار من
مدينه الى مدينه كان الجو يمطر نفس مطعو
اليوم مطب خفيف كان معي مظله ومعي حقيبتين
ومعي كوب قهوه
الاتحاد الاوروبي يعرف زين انه لا وجود
الاسلام الكهربائيه ولا وجود للمصاعد
درجات طويله وحقيبتين ثقيله جدا وانا عمري
وقتها كان 22 سنه او 21 سنه ما قدرت اشيل
حقيقتين اللي نصفها فيها اشياء ما احتاجها
اصلا ودرج طويل وامامي قطار بينطلق بيتحرك
على وقتها
حقيبتين
المظله واشيل الكوب وحط الكوب على الدرج
واطلع الين ما جات بنت بنتين كانوا خوات
او صديقات 13 12 سنه كلموني باللغه
الالمانيه بعدين تكلمنا بالانجليزي قاعده
تحتاج مساعده
تناظرت فيهم يعني عيب واحد عمره 21 22 سنه
تجي بنت اصغر منه بعشر سنين تعرض عليها
المساعده اخذت من العزه شوي قلت لا شكرا
ما احتاج المساعده ولو تفوت من الرحله
والناس على عجائب طالعين نازلين محطه قطار
وصلوا الى الاعلى شافوني على حاجه درجه
قعد اطلع نزلوا مره ثانيه هلفتين وما
كلموني اخذ الشنطه كل وحده شالت الشنطه من
جهه واطلعها فوق مره ثانيه
واطلعوا فوق ونزلوا اخذ المظله وطلعوا فوق
وانا طلعت فوق الحرج ماليني من فوق لتحتي
ماسك القهوه وقعدت اطلع الدرج هذا اللي
بقى الفتاه كانت ماسك المظله قاعده تلعب
فيها اعطتني المظله قالت تفضل
قالت لي جمله واحده
قالت خليك خفيف
كن خفيفا
حابب نصيحه لي انا ماشي عليها فنصيحه
الاولى للي بيسافروا العالم
تروح خفيف وارجع خفيف لما اقوله تعالي
معايا خلينا نسافر تقول لا روح لحالك روح
خفيف ووجع خفيف خفتك في الحركه صارت سهله
حظمت في ذلك اليوم
وقتها حلفت اني اغير من نمط السفر
واغير من اسلوبي في السفر جمله وتفصيلا
اتبعت من حينها سفرت هذه باللغه
الانجليزيه اكتشفت ان لو اسافر سنه كامله
كل اللي احتاجه موجود في هذه الحقيبه رغم
اني اصور وعندي معدات تصوير وحامل ثلاثي
وكاميرا
كل اللي احتاجه ما احتجت قطع من الملابس
تكفيني لمده سنه كامله وصلت الى قناعه انه
ما احتاج ان انا اسافر عشان الناس تشوفني
عشان اكشخ
تناظرني
ما تكون امنه يلاقي عندي ساعه ثمينه
يستنتج انه هذا ممكن يكون عنده فلوس فوقه
فبسطت من مظهري بالكامل
ما زال عندي هدف انا ابحث عن انسان
الشباب وين الانسان ابحث عنه ما شفته في
دول اوروبا صار في حاجز بيني وبينهم انا
صنعته
تخليت عن فكره بالكامل وغيرت الاسلوب
واتبعت
احد الاساليب اللي غيرتها في السفر هو
المسكن
المسكن والتنقل هل يتطلب ان تكون غنيا
لتسافر الان انا اقول لا في بعض الاحيان
المصفوفك خارج البلد يكون ارخص من مصروفك
في مدينه
اثنين دعمنا ما عندك مساحه ولا عندك حقائب
كل زادك ومتاعبك كل كل زادك ومتاعب ومتاعك
خلف ظهرك فانت لا تحتاج بالنسبه لي
لقناعتي الى مكان نظيف امن دافئ عشان انام
زين ومكانك في طولي ولا توقعني قصير سكنت
في جميع اماكن السكن في الكبسولات في بيوت
الشباب بيوت الضيافه كان الهدف اني اسكن
مع الناس او اني التقي في الناس بحكم اني
اسافر بشكل منفرد ما اسافر مع احد دائما
لحالي اطلع من السعوديه لحالي لكن هل انا
فعلا وحيد انا قاعد ابحث عن المجتمعات
قاعد التقي بهداء الناس كل يوم اقعد مع
ناس كل يوم اقعد مع شخصيات كلهم اقعد مع
ناس خلفياتهم تختلف دينيا وعلقين ومذهبيا
ومن جميع الصفات فصرت اسكن في اماكن
متشاركه مع الناس يخلينا التقي احد
الاماكن المهمه بالنسبه لي بيوت الشباب
بيئه خصبه توفر لي مسافرين اخرين من جميع
دول العالم
استمد اختي
من هؤلاء الشباب اذا نويت اني اسافر الى
كولومبيا ما ادخل جوجل ابحث عن كولومبيا
بلاقي عصابات وجوائم ومخدرات وقتل اسال
واحد توه راجع من كولومبيا التقت فيه
الشباب احكيلي عن كولومبيا يعطيني وجهه
نظر مسافر تخيل كم واحد سالني عن السعوديه
وانا في امريكا اللاتينيه ولو انا في
روسيا وانا في الصين قبل عام 2019 ما قبل
السياحه
كثير سالوني عن السعوديه
عن الصحراء وعن البحر الاحمر وعن الجبال
وعن الشمال وعن الجنوب كل هذه الخبره سقلت
من هذه الاماكن المشاركه
هذه الصوره كانت في احد الوحدات الاخيره
في
2022 في دوله اسمها داوس ما بين
فيتنام وكمبوديا في دوله صغيره بالنسبه
بنات اسمها جمهوريه لاوس
في اول يوم لي اول يوم وجدت نفسي بين خمسه
جنسيات الصوره هذه فيها السويد امراه من
السويد وامراه هولندا وشاب من المانيا من
امريكا وشاب من السعوديه وخلف نبائع يبيع
اكل الشوارع قاعدين نتعشى في الشارع علينا
وعفاء السفر وكابه المنظر وتعبانين لا
وجود المنقلب هنا كلنا ابتسامه تجمعنا لا
نعرف بعضنا البعض ما نعرف بعضنا اليوم
التقينا الاصل في الانسان هو الطيبه
والانسان اخذ انسان وان اختلف شكله ولونه
الان اثنين من هؤلاء موجودين في السعوديه
وفي الرياض
قبل هذا اللقاء كان يقولون خالد احنا في
اوروبا ما بيننا بين السعوديه مسافه ليش
ما نعرف هذا كله
بيوت الشباب
البيئه الخاصه اللي تخلي الانسان يلتقي
بالانسان ما زلت كنت ابحث عن الانسان
وابحث اني وابحث اني التقي فيه وانت
مجموعه واتعلم منه هذا اللي يزيد من شغف
على مدى 12 سنه في العالم واحد
المدينه مرتين او ازول العاصمه هل ازور
المدن الكبرى اصلا انني ابتعد واطلع من
منطقه الراحه واندمج مع المجتمعات
ومن جهه اخرى بعيدا عن المسافرين وبعيد عن
اصحاب الخبرات بعيدا عن مثل موجود في بيوت
الشباب العيش في الباديه
واحنا ابناء الباديه في نجد لكن تخيل معي
انك انت تكون في دوله كانت وحده من اكبر
الامبراطوريات على مستوى الكوكب من الصين
الى الشام امبراطوريه جنكيز خان الى درجه
البلد هذه مطار هاي يسمونه مطار الدولي
ويشوفون انسان عظيم رغم انه ارتكب مجازه
دخلت البلد وانا خلفيه تاريخيه
وعشت وسط ناس من عودي من ذبح الشاه عشان
ما يصير دمها على ارض في الكسخان
يقولون حنا نذبح الشاب البقر عشان ما تطلع
نقطه الدم وانت جاينا من السعوديه تبغى
تذبحها عندنا
ممنوع
احترام
عادات وتقاليد في الخيمه الدائريه اللي
قضيت فيها اسبوعين عادات صارمه جدا لا
يمكن للانسان ان يتخطاها
ادخل بايدن ادخل بقدم اليسار ممنوع تسخين
اهل التيامن اجلس في اليسار ما عجز في
اليمين عادات في السلام عادات في التحيه
عادات في اسلام المؤونه عادات في الاكل
ان خالفتها
هذا كان التهديد اللي يجيني في اخر يوم رب
الاسره
او ارتكب مخالفه شنيعه جدا قال انا راح
اكسر القانون المغولي وراح اجلسك في مكان
يمنع على اهل البلاد انهم يجلسون
قال انا اول مره في حياتي
وهذه اخر مره من السعوديه حتى الطفل كان
مستغرب
فعليا الطفل اسبوع كامل يطالع فيني
لكن الانسان
لا لغه ولا ثقافه ولا علق وعادات مختلفه
لكن لاجل قام وكسر كل هذه العادات فقط
لارتباطها بالانسان يخليه يسوي هذا كله
هي لغه واحده هي الابتسامه
ومن جهه اخرى ايضا الحياه مع الناس
تخيل معي من الصحراء ومن معي صعبه اذا وسط
الجبال لا الوصول الى الجبال صحن ولا
المغادره من الجبال ايضا سهل
ذكرت كلمه الشعوب في القران مره واحده
شعوب وقبائل شعوب اما اذا مفصل فيه احنا
شعوب
في الكره الارضيه باكملها ذكرت في القران
مره واحده
ذكر معنى الجبال الثلاثه
الارض الدعوه في التامل في الطبيعه
والجبال اوتاد ولعلكم تاملت في محاضره
يعني كيف حسيت ان الانسان صغير جدا لمن
يوقف وقدام الجبل هائل
فكيف انك انت تتخطى هذه الجبال وتلاقي ناس
عايشه وسط قويه الجبال تحيتهم من جميع
الاتجاهات
تجيهم فوق الجبل
يزرعونها وياكلون مما يسمعون
اذا كان احد اجازاتي الناس مبسوط
يتسوح نعم يتسوح لكن يتعلم
هذه الباميه في طاجكستان
اصغر نقطه موجوده على خريطه الطاجيك نهر
صغير ما بينه وبين افغانستان الا نهر
لو اصوت اشوف الافغاني في الجهه الثانيه
ناس منسيين عايشين لحالهم
فعليا دقات الباب ودخلت وقعدت اهدى اسيا
الوسطى هم قمه الكرم لا تخطيط مسبق وصلت
الى المكان وقلت انا ابجلس معاكم معي تمر
عربون الضيافه
الدوله هذه جمهوريه طاجكستان الاسلاميه
ولا مع مركز متطوع مركز الملك سلمان
الاخ ابراهيم كان في شهر ابريل في نصف
السنه عامه 2019 وجحته في الصيف
برؤيه مختلفه تماما
اللغه الفرنسيه
كانوا سعداء بطريقه
انسولف طول اليوم كيف نسولف
هنا وجهات كبير في السن من الصوره حافظ
خريطه العالم بطريقه ارعبتني كيف انسان في
القريه هذه محاط في الجبال صورها بالدهون
من فوق القول هذه الجهه فيضان
اباد نصف القريه وغير اتجاه الماء تبلله
ووجعه بين بيوتهم من جديد
رجال في اسيا الوسطى بين احد جبال الباميه
يسالني عنك اوراقه
عن امريكا اللاتينيه وافتح له جوالي اوريه
الصور يطالع بدهشه اخر شيء
كان ما تخيلت انه في يوم من الايام
يرسل لي واحد
هو كان هناك قبل سنتين من امريكا
اللاتينيه ابتسمت له بلغه الاشاره للانسان
الشاب هذا الى الان انا اول رجل كبير في
السن الى الان على تواصل معه
عيد الحج كان هناك
من بيت لبيت عيد عليهم من قريه قويه اصبح
جويه
اول مره في حياتي اتذوق الزبادي وهو يطلع
فريش قدامي حامض
اول مره استمتع بطعم الخياره والطماطم من
المدفعه بديهيات موجوده عندنا لكن اول مره
استمتع بالطعام الطعام اهل القريه اللي
فقدناه في المدينه وجدت في هذه القريه هل
سواء فيني اثر نعم هل استمتع بالعواصم لا
ابحث عن الانسان الانسان في العصر مشغول
مو فاضي لك الانسان في العاصمه الساعه
7:00 الصبح بيوصل دوامه تطلب لنا مساعده
لكن ابتعد عن المدينه ادخل القضيه وشوف
كيف وجهت نظر الانسان لك وان شافك مسافر
يعطيك فضل العظيم جدا
لانه الانسان هو الارتحاد وليس الاستقبال
وبالحديث عمل الجبال
وكيف ان الانسان صغير امام الجبال ما
تخيلتني في يوم من الايام اصحى من نومي
واشوف البركان
منبه خافض الصوره لمن هذا كانت واعتماده
في منطقه اسمها انتيكوا بعد وحده السير
يوم واحد
وصلنا الى القمه ونمنا كملت هذه الصباح
لقينا الجبل يصبح علينا
بدخانه
هذا الجبل بعد سنتين
وغضب واباد كل حوله في عام 2018
ابعاد القوابل كامل وبيدت بيها بالنار
ماذا يوجد بداخل الجبال هي دعوه للتامل
ذكر معنى الجبال الثلاثه
الثبات الركائز على الارض كلها من الجبال
داخلها كفوف
جوها عكس الجو حار وجهها داخلها براكين
تغلي نوع ترضع تفور
في
فضول ابي اشوف بس اللي بداخل المسلمين
كم عدد البراكين الحيه في العالم على من
بصره اوقف واناظر تحت اشوف
النار قاعده تغلي وتفور ممكن في اي لحظه
يخرج ويبيد محوله بالكامل هنا دعوه للتامل
السفر للتدبر
للتعرف على الناس
للتامل يجعلك تعرف ان الانسان هو اصغر
مخلوق في هذا الكوكب
وعلى صعيد اخر في دعوه اخرى للتامل في
غابات الامازون
تخيل معنا انك انت تكون قاعد وسط الطبيعه
وانت لا شيء سوى الطبيعه هذه هذا اجمل
غروب شفته في حياتي
كمان دخلت وسط ناس من اطباعهم اكل لحم لحم
البشر
يعني الشعب ياكل لحم البشر
ومعزولين عن الدوله باكملها
يعيشون وسط جنه انقى نواء في حياتك ممكن
تتنفسه في هذه الارض ويئه الارض الامازون
الغروب الهواء النقي
الاسماك في هذه النهر تاكل لحم البشره
واسماك البيبان انا كنت التماسيح المداري
الحمى الصفا ما يشعرون فيها فما تجد انت
تخاف من الامراض ولا تتامل لديها ما يسمى
بصوت الغابه الغابه صامته هادئه تغمض عينك
فجاه الغابه كلها تصيح
ولا دعوه للتامل
كله بعبارات بسيطه جدا
اختم فيها المحاضره
اتمنى انك ما اقتنعت ان السفر ما يحتاج
الى شجاعه السفر يحج الالهام لا يتطلب ان
تكون شجاعا لا يتطلب ان تكون غنيا مثل
تسافر اذا ركزت على السكن والنقل راح توفر
ثمانين بالميه من مزايا الوحده
ابحث عن هدوء
الهدوء اطلع للمدينه الهواء النقي كن
خفيفا اذا الالمانيه
والاخص هذا كله بايه واحده قل سيوف الارض
اما الرباني فانظر كيف بدا الخلق هذا امر
بالتحرك قل سيوف الارض
يصيبك بالموقف
بالحركه بركه
وسلامتكم نقطه اخيره
اتوقع الوقت انتهى لكن خليني سؤال واحد
بعد الجوله هذي كلها كيف حتكون نظرتك
للمدينه لما يكون المدينه عدد سكانها 30
مليون 20 مليون مكتظه لا هواء نقي لا اكل
من المزرعه كل شيء فيها مصطنع وحتى
الانسان فيها اصبح مصطنع الكاتب فهد
الاحمدي قال جمله في كتابه
كاتب مثلا اعلى بسفره يسمي هذه الحياه
بالاقفاص الذهبيه
لانه كل شيء فيها مصطنع حتى الفنادق خمس
نجوم
لمن اطلع من منطقه الراحه وادخل في هذه
الحياه
بديت اتفاعل واسالكم ايهما تفضل هذا القفص
الذهبي
ام الحياه مع الناس والجواب لكم والسلام
[تصفيق]